want to actually advocate for men
and show them that we're not all like
that yeah no it's it's interesting um i
don't is it
so in the u.s um i know if someone gets
divorced and they have a kid with a girl
in certain states they have to pay 25 of
their after-tax income per kid
um i don't think it's as bad here no no
is it similar or no
i don't think it's
it can be similar but i think what the
thing is i think the us is a bit more
cutthroat yeah yeah in terms of english
law we go by case by case and there's
more of uh
there's a lot more fairness i think
from what i've seen so far which is good
because i mean in america you have
community property states which are just
like completely just cut the house the
assets in the middle who cares what
happened in the case yeah and that's
horrible because some cases are really
unique and they deserve attention but
then you have equity distribution states
in america some states and uh
which is what you expect of the law to
look at every single case
and uh yeah the the one that i was
involved in was an equity equitable
distribution state
so the fact is the ex-wife actually
didn't fulfill the factors
um so that actually what gained like
that worked in favor of my client
what does fulfill the factors mean so
the statutory factors for he was in the
state of colorado and in the state of
colorado you have statutory factors for
example
you know
i don't know how people are going to
take this but it is the factors for
example if she wants 50 percent
she will basically get whatever
percentage from the assets it become uh
like compensate compensating for her
contribution to the marriage if she took
care of children as a percentage if she
gave up things like homemaking
as opposed to his 50 percent does that
make sense yeah so she can it could be
70 you know 20
yeah like that no that's that's really
cool that's really interesting when i
found out about the stage i was like
that's brilliant yeah and coming into
property states are really scary like
california is
that's that's the one where i heard this
guy was like going to retire and then he
couldn't retire because he his wife left
him and took the kid to japan
yeah and like
it's crazy because i guess in some
states like the courts are separate like
the courts for like child support and
the divorce courts so when he went to
child support like to get child support
they would just say oh you weren't in
the kid's life the last six months but
they don't put in the fact that like she
wasn't letting him be
yeah so it's kind of it's very um
especially in the u.s here i looked up i
i think they get like 13 to like 20 ish
per kid if that was correct right is
that yeah i don't know if that's it's
not as cutthroat i think as the u.s from
what i learned but that's generally but
again they look at each and every case
which is important because we can't we
can't say it's definitely gonna go this
way differently right right
okay sorry that was just interesting
that's why i asked okay um so i was
gonna say on on a slightly slightly on a
tangent but similar topic
uh fun fact like one of my friends who
studied in law in the uk
i actually asked him about the topic of
um
you know like prenups
and i said like you know it must be a
good idea right you're safeguarding
yourself you're safeguarding each person
then you feel like it's a little bit
more comfortable going into the
relationship and i said like surely
that's like a good way to go you know in
a trusting way and he was like actually
like there are loopholes just because
you have a prenup does not mean you are
going to get away
you know without compensation so
um it might work a little bit better in
america but let's say in the rest of the
world that's that's not the case and
he's like if you're smart especially
like people who have
wealth from their family old family
um they actually like when their kids
get married they actually like they
don't put things or assets under their
children's name for a reason because if
the
woman tries to divorce the man and try
to get the assets they can't because
it's under the entire family rather than
under an individual so he was saying
like there are ways
that you can so you can put your
sister's name you can get your brother
so it's like you know like it's it's
it's not yours it's it's the family and
so if that's the way that something's
named then you could that that you can
kind of get away with it but you cannot
just say well i've got prenup so this is
pre yeah and that's scary no it scares
me it is and it's hard because i'm very
pro-marriage in like a family sense but
i understand like why guys don't want to
get married
you know it like makes sense because i'm
like if i had if i could possibly lose
this much of my assets i wouldn't want
to get married either if the like the
roles were reversed and what's more
terrifying is that you don't even have
to get married to get the same treatment
that's the you can't even cohabit
because it's horrible you kind of it's
like it's like they legally twist their
arm like they say you know what no then
let's not get married and they say ah
but if you live with her for this many
years it's like
i actually i don't know if anyone is
canadian in the audience who might know
but actually i heard that in canada
maybe i might be making this up but i
thought i heard that it doesn't you
don't even have to marry if you've been
living with your partner for a certain
amount of years that automatically that
person can try and get money from you i
mean i don't i don't know i don't know i
think that's i think they're that's true
but i might be wrong so if anyone if i'm
wrong please correct me
okay i'm sorry i got a little off sorry
no no it was it's interesting that's
okay um so today we're talking about is
the bar set low for men so the reason um
that i thought of this was because i was
like scrolling through my tick tock and
there's this trend going around where
it's like girls will say well the bar is
so low for men and then you know explain
and so i wanted to show you guys a video
ish if you want to pull it up
um
[Music]
it's
basically a compilation of girls when
they talk about
you know how how low the bar is because
you know between men and women
apparently
you know women are the ones with the low
standards you know men just have the
highest yeah
yeah yeah
wait so i i see that so so the girls are
saying on social media that they have
low standards for men is that what
they're trying to say sort of you're
you'll see in a second
i'm ready for this one let me see what's
going on all right sam's first
yes
guys sam sam's going for it so i guess
while we're waiting for representation
while we're waiting for ish to uh set
this up um who do you guys think has
higher standards men are women just off
the bat
women official women women 100
from a biological standpoint definitely
the girls women
women women yeah see this it's
interesting because everyone genuinely
agrees here i could tell i was like this
group is going to be based
i think like
it's i think it's important that like we
obviously will be talking about the gen
general trends of things but then
obviously there is
there are outliers right so um from a
biological standpoint it makes sense
that the girl's more picky because
you get pregnant
you're gonna be nine months your body's
gonna get distorted by the way
you're never gonna be the same and it's
not fun giving birth so to subject
yourself you you really have to
you know really pick someone whereas a
guy you almost can
forget about it that's why women once
when they um
when they ask questions like why can't
we do the same things as men why can't
we sleep around the same as men the
answer is right there you can get
pregnant it's not complicated i hate
that comparison women go off on a
tangent but you can do this so we can do
this you clearly can't because usually
not just that it's also a pair bonding
too like
you know
if you want to